Speaker 1: The Donald Trump rape trial has
started. A lot to discuss here as well. Started
yesterday. NPR has a good primer. We might call it
Five Things to Know as Jean Carroll's civil trial
begins against Donald Trump. Jury selection
begins Tuesday. This is the defamation suit
brought against Trump by Jean Carroll. Late last
year, Carroll accused Trump of causing significant
pain and suffering, lasting psychological harms,
loss of dignity and invasion of her privacy.
Trump's lawyers say the statute under which
the assault claim was brought against Trump
violates due process. The core of this is that
Carroll claims Trump raped her in the changing
room of the Bergdorf Goodman Department store
in Manhattan in the 1990s. The suit says as a
result of the pain and suffering caused by that
sexual assault, she has not been able to sustain
a romantic relationship since that day. Trump's
lawyers are expected to argue Carroll's nearly 30
year old claims cannot be proved and that she was
motivated by potential book sales and publicity.
Important to know, Carroll has sued Trump already
twice, and both matters are still active. There's
the defamation suit from November of 2019 and
a November 22 suit filed under New York's Adult
Survivors Act, which opens a one year window
when people alleged sexual assault to bring
civil claims older than those that would normally
be allowable. So that is happening. There are not
cameras in the courtroom. There are not cameras
in the courtroom as far as I was able to research
this morning. A couple other notes. The trial in
Manhattan federal court is expected to last 5 to
7 days, reports Business Insider. And Donald Trump
is not there in person, Trump said in October on
Troth Central this Miss Bergdahl Dorf Goodman case
is a complete con job. It's a hoax and a lie. Like
all the other hoaxes that have been played on me
for the last seven years. It is unclear whether
Trump will attend any of the trial in person
for the time being. Trump has not been there.
Jean Carroll is indeed there. The reason I bring
this up is not because anything in particular has
transpired at the trial, yet that is newsworthy or
noteworthy, but because I do think it's important
not to forget that this is yet another legal
issue that is facing Trump, that is in the news,
whose outcome could could impact Trump's 2024 run.
We'll follow it. We'll let you know what happens.